bonsoir à karine déchets golovkov merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france arbour cette invention de sergueï
lavrov n'a pas été très très longue il
faut dire qu'il a donné une conférence
de presse juste avant qui a été beaucoup
plus longue à retenir en tout cas
puisqu'il est à la tribune de l'onu il a
plaidé en faveur
d'un règlement de régler les conflits
justement à l'onu mais aussi au conseil
de sécurité deux plateformes d'éthyle à
privilégier
oui bonsoir
effectivement alors qu'il était rentré
extrêmement dans le détail de chaque
conflit lors de la conférence de presse
là il est allé en quelque sorte à
l'essentiel et il a rappelé une règle de
base mais qui semble être quelque peu
oublié aujourd'hui c'est lorsqu'il n'y a
plus de rapports de droit on rentre dans
un rapport de force et c'est pour cela
qu'il a rappelle l'importance de
structures de dialogue mais qui
fonctionne sur la boit sur la base de
traiter sur la base d'accords qu'il faut
absolument respecter il a rappelé
également le danger de contourner ces
mécanismes qui sont posées qui sont
acceptées par la communauté
internationale en essayant de mettre en
place des structures
conjoncturels dont l'efficacité est très
relatif puisque en fait elles servent en
général des intérêts politiques très
précis et non pas la résolution d'un
conflit dans l'intérêt de tout ça donc
c'est effectivement important pour pour
la russie qui reste toujours dans cette
ligne classique de volonté de maîtriser
les confus par le droit et non pas par
la force il ya en ce sens une certaine
logique puisque effectivement
les conflits deviennent en quelque sorte
choix pas moment où ils sortent du
domaine juridique
mais il ya aussi des limites dans cette
approche on a réussit parfaitement
consciente
c'est que
le droit international qui est à la base
donc de toutes ces régulations et les
mêmes le résultat d'un rapport de force
l'onu est le résultat de la seconde
guerre mondiale de la victoire
des alliés du rôle important de l'urss
qui permet à la russie aujourd'hui
d'avoir le siège permanent au conseil de
sécurité
et c'est pour ça aussi que la russie
défend justement l'histoire puisque
c'est l'histoire qui permet d'expliquer
les situations telles qu'elles sont
aujourd'hui donc il ya une interaction
s'ils voulaient toutes manières entre le
droit et la force mais il est important
justement d'essayer de maîtriser ces
régulations alors justement vous parlez
du conseil permanent de sécurité que
l'on m'adresse il dispose au sein de
l'instance justement la russie qui se
démarquent puisque sergei lavrov il a
clairement plaidé en faveur d'un
élargissement de la composition du
conseil de sécurité à l'asie et à
l'afrique aussi oui alors il ya deux
choses 1
qu'il faut distinguer au niveau du
conseil de sécurité il ya d'une part les
membres permanents qui ont un droit de
veto et il ya les autres membres donc la
russie plaide effectivement pour un
élargissement de la composition en
général les pensées de sécurité de l'onu
bon c'est une proposition qui discute je
suis mais en revanche elle maintient et
c'est important ch ou au droit de veto
parce que les droits de veto a été
durement acquis par les baies justement
après la seconde guerre mondiale et
c'est aussi le garant d'une certaine
puissance et d'un certain équilibre des
forces revenir dessus serait remettre en
cause complètement l' équilibre des
forces un qui a été atteindre alors au
menu aussi de son intervention
les menaces sécuritaires en salle guy
lavoie qui a évoqué le traité les forces
nucléaires à portée intermédiaire avec
une demande de moratoire là dessus il ya
aussi la l'initiative russe de
conventions de convention de lutte
contre les armes chimiques et
biologiques toujours la russie reste en
attente d'une réponse à ce propos puis a
évoqué les autres conflits notamment le
conflit
israélo-palestinien donc les menaces
aussi sécuritaire et les conflits
les conflits existent toujours je dirais
qu'ils sont toujours existé à partir du
moment où il ya eu que trois êtres
humains sur terre il ya eu des conflits
donc il ya quand même peu de chances
pour qu'il disparaisse un jour en
revanche en voulant proposer des
mécanismes de régulation qui sont posées
dans le cadre de traités et qui sont
donc accepté par les différentes parties
potentiel ou qu'on fiche il y a ainsi
une volonté comme on disait dedans
globez h ces rapports de force dans des
rapports de droit afin de maîtriser leur
évolution ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il
n'y aura aucun conflit qui va pouvoir
émerger derrière mais ce qui veut dire
que l'on peut essayer en tout cas déjà
d'en prévenir une grande partie est de
maîtriser une certaine manière ce qui se
passe en ce qui concerne le conflit
israëlo palestinien c'est un bon flic et
pam extrêmement spécifique qui est
presque un qui est très très ancien et
ça montre aussi peut-être dans quelle
mesure
il n'ya pas des limites si vous voulez a
cette capacité de régulation des
conflits régionaux ch la communauté
internationale à certaines visions qui
ne correspondent pas toujours aux
visions politiques et des populations
sur place et des élites dirigeantes
sur place aussi donc il ya quand même si
vous voulez une fois pas non plus
imaginer que l'onu et la commutation en
général soit une panacée qui va
permettre de résultats tous les conflits
qui existent c'est une plateforme parmi
d'autres mais beaucoup de choses
dépendent des états et je pense qu'il ne
faut pas oublier non plus que beaucoup
des choses dépendent aussi de la culture
politique des adhésifs dirigeante en du
niveau de économique un sociale dans les
sociétés parce que il est évident aussi
que la pauvreté l'instabilité sont des
facteurs qui vont développer les
conflits merci beaucoup à vous à karine
abéché golovkov professeur invité à
l'université d'état de moscou s'ajoutent